التحديد الاوكرانيه الصحه او ظل مجرده
تهديد يطرح سؤالا هاما كيف تتعامل معه
موسكو التاهب ثم التاهب احدى الطرق هي
تكثيف التواجد العسكري في المنطقه
على البحر الاسود مشاهدينا سنشاهد الان
خريطه الانتشار العسكري الروسي في شبه
الجزيره القرمه في ميناء سيناء وهي باتت
الان محميه بطبقتين من اذرعه التطبيق
العائمه عند مداخل الميناء في الجزء
الخلفي من المرفاء حيث توجد ارصفه تزوج
بالوقود تتم حمايه السفن بواسطه المزيد من
اذرعه التطويق العائمه وهنا يمكننا رؤيه
التعزيزات العسكريه المتزايده البحريه
الروسيه في محيطه ميناء نيفارس السكن بما
في ذلك
خالص ان نفطي والذي اعلنت كيا با ايضا
فهو اخيرا التعزيزات ان نشرت في الوقت بين
الحادي عشر والخامس عشر من الشهر الجاري
وفي محيط الميناء لجات روسيا لواحده من
اهداف الغواصات في العالم غواصه كيلو
المحسنه هي النسخه المحصله التي تتميز
بتكنولوجيا التخفي مع نطاق قتاليا ممتده
لضرب الاهداف الارضيه والصحيه وتحت الماء
كما لجات موسكو لسفن دوريا من فئه بروجيكت
220 فتضمن مهامها الراصده وحمايه السفن
اثناء العبور في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه والمياه الاقليميه لروسيا وكانت
هذه محمد مصطفى الذي تلقت فيه روسيا
الضربه الاكبر في هذه الحرب